this is you know I know it's not a
conical pendulum but we're still going
through the same kinds of thing we have
drawn a diagram right I put on the
physical forces that are there what do I
do next I did step one mr. draw step two
is trig and geometry so that I can work
out like this thing when I get towards
resolving US forces which way is
everything facing okay so what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to take part of
this diagram this part where the forces
are draw that out separately so that I
can understand a little bit
okay so there's the normal voice right
now which way are all of the forces and
all their magnitudes going when I start
to resolve this thing okay so if you've
got some colors there you can see
there's a horizontal component like this
and you can see importantly that this
horizontal component of the normal force
it's centripetal it's headed towards a
so that's good that's what we wanted to
do right so I'll work out what that is
in a second and then you've got the
vertical component which is heading up
like your it's been alright so have a
look with me what angles can we use in
here what can we take advantage of so
there's some there's some parent
alliance there's some alternate angles
if you do you work I'm pretty sure you
should find you know er you'll have
theta
alternate angles and because this is the
normal right that means that these two
are complementary so I've got 90 minus
theta they're sad all right 90 minus
theta 90 that means that theater is up
in this corner all right okay
buy the same alternate angles you can
see theater will be over here okay and
that's all you need to work out what the
magnitudes of all the forces are okay
prison the vertical one right
you've got adjacent and you got
hypotenuse we've seen this a few times
before right it's tiny get the hang of
it this is clearly going to be n plus
theta right and conversely you'll have n
sine theta in the horizontal direction
so now I've resolved everything now I
can put it in terms of vertical and
horizontal and say well vertically I
want to be going up and down
horizontally I'm going in this second
right so you've got n cos theta going up
and you've got mg going down right and
those should be equal to each other
right so and cos theta equals mg nothing
too dramatic there what's happening
horizontally you've only got a single
force acting horizontally at the moment
anyway okay so you've got and sine theta
and it's going towards the center so
that should be equal to it now we used
to writing M R Omega squared first right
but being that this is Bank tracks and
we're kind of thinking more about cars
but we don't see we're not usually
driving around like oh wow I'm taking
this corner you know Payan 3 radians per
second so probably rather than mov these
people do em b squared on are okay i
think that that makes more sense okay
because we will no linear velocity now
this is in an oiled ideal world okay
we're going around and the only force is
acting are exactly balancing each other
out you'll see shortly what happens when
that is not the case okay well I want to
work out well what is that speed at
which I should take this corner okay so
how am I going to work this out I've got
V squared there that's what I want to
work out okay so if I call this one hmm
which way should I go and what should I
do
should I add subtract any takers
what's the cleanest way to get to v
square and a nice simple sort of
equation just for V squared and then
hence B the coefficient divided
shouldn't win right because that will
get rid of the ends it'll get rid of the
ends and you can if we do it this way
you'll just get ten pick up right which
will be useful for its own thing okay so
if I divide so I should have said two
divided by one end will cancel you just
get that MS will also cancel what am I
gonna get V squared on G alright so now
if I just rearrange this a little bit
v squared equals G yeah okay put a box
around that put a box around it because
what this tells you is the optimum speed
to take this turn this is the optimum or
velocity to speed it's all squared so it
doesn't matter okay this is the optimist
be given the radius of the road or the
curve for the room and whatever angle
you're in banked at okay now that's fine
that's good but that's sort of assuming
the roads already there like it has a
given radius it's gonna go that far and
you can measure carve the angle is right
if I were a road designer okay I
actually am in the position where I get
to decide what these are based on this
right so I'm looking at this from a very
different point of view okay I'm making
the road and I'm thinking food how far
should I make this okay because I can
you know I can put whatever amount of
dirt and concrete and stuff to make this
kind of height okay so how will I do
this it's a bit of a fancy algebraic
trick remember I told you this diagram
is actually way off scale right this
angle theta is not really going to be
that high and when you think about it
like you just think about the roads that
you've traveled on and if you've been on
a highway and you've seen terms like
this there'll be very very gentle
inclines right in order to take these
terms okay so in other words you have
small values of theta
okay now one of the things that you
might remember from when you first did
the tree non tree of sorry the calculus
of trigonometric functions right is that
tan theta right and sine theta are very
close together for small values of theta
right because they look like I'll just
use this empty space
he is sine and then here is 10 and then
it's gone too far
there's that asymptote pile - right
so in here it pretty much the same thing
or the difference between them is
negligible okay so I can say sine of
theta is going to be roughly equal to
tan theta all right okay now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to substitute
that into this line maybe I'll call this
3 so I can do this ok so I'm going to
sub in 2 so instead of tan theta over
here I'm going to say that's sine theta
and it's roughly equal to v square da gr
close enough okay and the reason why is
is useful the reason why I would go to
sine theta is because I know what sine
theta is in terms of these distances
here right this hypotenuse is D and it's
opposite side to the angle is H that's
what I'm trying to find right so this is
really equal to opposite on hypotenuse
okay yeah I find the road designer and I
want to work out how high should I make
this embankment right I just have to
multiply D across and then look at what
we've got here okay before we had
optimum speed that's that's if you the
roads already there and it already has a
given radius and they give an angle okay
but here are in the opposite position
feel like I can decide what I want the
road to be then this line will give you
the optimum height of the embankment
okay now notice what it depends on it
depends on let's let's go from the
bottom it depends on our right that's
that's the radius of this road that's
probably gonna be decided for you right
the council's like look this is where
the road has to go so they they provide
that to you depends on gravity constant
depends on D what was D again that's
that's the road width isn't it again
that's decided for you sigh okay well we
need three lanes for this highway or
it's one lane or whatever okay now the
final piece is V squared right so it's
like look if you learn where your ruin
has to be how wide you know gravity and
then if you know a required speed or if
you what a particular optimist be like
say oh I don't know a speed limit right
you say look this is on a highway people
should be taking this curve at 110 km/h
right instead of being in this position
where you're the drive and you're like
how fast should I go you're in this
position you say look I know how fast
they should go and so I'm going to
substitute that into here and get a
height out does that make sense okay so
this is all in an ideal world where
everything is optimized and everything
is nice and perfect right optimal speed
automatic for everything but we don't
live in an ideal world do people take
corners at all different speeds people
have cars of all different masses okay
so what's going to happen is for
instance you know suppose this is corner
here right and I'm just a little bit
more reckless than you so I'm like okay
speed limits 110 I just go ahead and I
take it 110 but everyone else all the
normal people they're like look at how
tight that curve is right so people come
in and they slow down they approach it
maybe ninety kilometers an hour okay or
maybe you have like a really heavy car
okay so when you have a heavy car
there's going to be more fortunate
acting in this direction in this
direction right and I've got a light car
so it's going to go so we have to
account for all of these things okay
this is an idea well you can roll over
all that off we're gonna draw a new
diagram for a non-ideal world okay and I
need more space